uh brian i have to tell you something
please
so i met brendan's mom
and she told me specifically it's my
girl she said and she said i have to say
it like this you're her favorite now no
no no she said tell brian i said hi
yeah and she made me say it like that
she said you got to say like that and
then she kissed me on the cheek my mom
did yes she did
she kissed me on the cheek we have a
thing yeah yeah
no then my mom i started the groom and
she's like i think you like black guys
now i'm like what hey what the [ __ ]
[Music]
you said ig's down ij's down oh there's
a picture of
yeah she and i talked about things and
you'd have to call me dad and that was
what we were talking about that'd be
weird i can't just call you uh
step brian no step bro call me daddy
step daddy brian you asked me for some
pocket change it has to be daddy you're
gonna have to give me allowance and [ __ ]
yeah go get some go get some hard candy
mom and i have some stuff and be gone
for about 30 minutes daddy needs about
30 to himself with your mom what yeah
wait what crying all right your mom's
your mom's a good looking woman though
thanks man she's amazing she's so sweet
you met nubby too yeah on nubby
bridge or back sorry back was there how
about they sit him
they sit him right into the on the stage
you know how tommy
the girl running it goes i'm so sorry
she goes the because it's a whole new
staff because you know kova stuff like
we have a new staff they didn't know
they put your mom and then your best
friends in the front row oh my god she
has and any kind we've ever had they
hate that i hate that and she goes do
you mind i go i don't like it so i just
i literally didn't turn left the whole
time look at that right there
yeah
are you grabbing her leg like that
because she popped her leg up
it's a
mom looks strong and athletic she's got
a frame yeah mom's like five ten almost
five yeah that's where you get your and
your dad had six you know you were you
had to be big yeah you met you met uh
papa shop though you meant yeah i met
him you spent some time with was the
time i brought the shop smart guy i
brought chappelle to uh the cu game yeah
oh you did yeah how was that we got uh
that was fun sweet right on the boulder
in boulder wow because i was beautiful i
was doing uh press with uh mcchesney and
scott hastings oh you were yeah
mcchesney goes dude come to the game i
got [ __ ] shows tonight dude he goes
no it's uh it's at noon it's at noon
against sc right we go [ __ ] so i need a
bunch of tweaks i brought chappelle
david lucas my other feature
jay my dad and me good game and kyle
thank you dude no no
no usc was very good
very very good yeah yeah yeah they meet
the [ __ ] was the guy you took a picture
of it another guy who did a radio thing
with it i did i did that's willie b
that's my definitely
the best yeah yeah good guy he's like
he's a big ski he's like a car guy yeah
yeah i like that guy he's like denver
hall of fame right now oh yeah dude he's
he's been on air i think
for almost 30 years but like the voice
of denver yeah man i like that guy yeah
tim lewis and floor wax like willie b's
like the guy
and like i was telling chappelle like uh
willie b
is like like no one's going to call i'm
not i would never call myself a gearhead
yeah like i wouldn't even consider rogue
in a gearhead to me like
to me a head is a guy who
if there's a you know
you replace the pulleys or there's you
know body work or it rims can
dude he can build a car from frame to
that's the end he knows his [ __ ] he's
one of those
like rogan was on there burr goes on
there bert christopher goes on there
like that's like that's the place that's
the staple in colorado yeah
i i you know me i i shook his hand i
kind of kind of did a half man hug and i
and i was like jeez i took him in i go
that's what he said kid yeah kind of a
big muscle he's like brian likes like
men's bodies right yes yes he does he's
good his hands are he's a big strong guy
yeah dude oh yeah in kentucky
you'll remember you gotta remember i've
known him almost [ __ ] i'm 38 now
probably damn almost 20 years because
remember i was doing pr when i played
for the buffs you he would be the guy
would do interviews with and then when i
was doing local fighting ring of fire in
denver he would be the guy i'd go to and
then i fought in the ufc when i fought
in denver at broomfield and i was an
ultimate fighter he was the guy i would
go to wow and then now i'm doing stand
up every year i'm there i do stan you
know i see him cool all those guys so
yeah they're so good yep great it was
crazy being back it was crazy being back
at cu man was it you make fun of me and
you didn't know this i we were in a
suite and in my head i was like oh we're
just trying to see you gay my dad's
going it's not a big deal you know you
you're like you and i are the same we
don't smell the roses ever we just we
can keep it moving
sociopaths we're narcissists keep it
going like what what's tomorrow like
yesterday yeah or even 10 years you hit
the [ __ ] out of it i forget i forget i
forget i just forget so uh we're driving
my dad chappelle jay david kyle we're
all driving the cu game and i know
exactly where to park right [ __ ]
school there and well so we get out and
i'm going to think about it and then we
walk into the indoor gymnasium you have
to get there to get to our seats
and that indoor gymnasium i haven't been
to
since um i was a senior there but the
reason uh and it's it's like it's old
school it's not updated but it has a
rubber uh flooring and that's where we
do our 5 a.m winter condition called
dirty dozens where they would try and
break all the guys on the team
and i get in there i smell exactly what
i smelled at five in that morning and i
was like oh my gosh
i was like oh my god and i look down and
you know people are walking in their
seats so they're stepping all over it
but there's a line and i remember that
line because
the dirty dozens uh it's a it's 12
different stations conditioning stations
and compete against different team so
you do all 12 stations at 5 00 am but if
you knocked over a cone knocked over
ladder false start started late came in
last place there was a coach like an
intern who would go around and just make
marks on the sheet and he'd come over
and you wouldn't know what he's doing to
make marks make marks and when i first
did when i was a sophomore i was richard
sophomore there i'm like why the [ __ ] is
guy going around making marks well
those marks are for any mistake anybody
made that's how many sprints the entire
team had to do at the end oh
this is a story brian is this a real
story i love this
i know
yeah i covered a little bit on below the
belt but i know you love it so i'm going
to read that so and matt mcchesney and
lawrence fricker can and joel clatt can
co-sign this one day just like you were
just having
it's winter cam nobody's doing very good
it's 5 a.m cole brennan was on the team
he drove me there who passed away rest
in peace but and went to play for uh
hawaii and finished fourth in heisman
anyway
so you guys making marks so those
conditioning drills you're exhausted and
gary bryant goes all right everybody
line up time to run sprints time to pay
our dues for the mistakes we made and
we're like you know you should be like
12 or 15 you know which is tough that's
a lot which is tough which is tough and
and those are 40 yard sprints
uh around about 50.
yeah so uh one of the when i was a
senior one time we did 40 sprints
now let me tell you something about 40
sprints after all that
and it ends at 6 30 in the morning
here's what's crazy so
most people can do 20 but you have to do
a certain amount of time or it doesn't
count so you actually did 60
so when we're on third i will never
forget this when we're on 35
everyone's so exhausted some guys are
just they physically can't get up and
run they're like on their back
hyperventilating there's
you know the the the
people there to help them out if they
were gonna die or whatever like recessed
statum but if you didn't make it on the
line you're kicked off the team if
you're like on the team if you're like a
starter or like a captain if you didn't
if your hand was online when you were
supposed to up they blow the whistle you
were kicked off the team
so we wanted it so bad i remember
putting my hand on crawling to the lines
my legs the lactic acid was so bad i
remember putting my hand down on the
line just to make i made with a [ __ ]
inch of the whistle i had my hand in the
line i was so
um overworked i was throwing up but i
have anything in my stomach so it was
like that bile throw up i assume right i
was so sweaty all sweaty i just remember
my
hand covered in vomit and the guy next
to me is doing the same thing throwing
up and we still made the 40 yard sprints
we still made it everybody made it you
come out of that differently yeah that's
the point all this stuff like and and so
again you didn't change your deal you
didn't realize this i made sure david
didn't see this i didn't think it would
affect me so that hit me and i and then
i'm going through my head all those
dirty dozens cold breath that made me
emotional coat brandon passed away
driving me there i'm scraping the ice
off his car and i'm going through all
this [ __ ] that i've been through and you
guys got to realize i wasn't a
scholarship player at first i was a
walk-on
so you're looked at like a piece of [ __ ]
until you earn your spot if ever you see
a walk on the team know that kid is
there for the love of the game because
the [ __ ] that i had to go through is
different than what those other
scholarship players had to go to to earn
that scholarship
so i outworked everybody
so that's triggering me right but not in
a bad way i'm like oh my god i did work
in here like a navy seal almost like i
don't mean to compete
i don't mean to compare it to you can
though combat but i think d1 sports like
d1 wrestling and it sounds like do you
want but that's my thing i don't think
so anymore i think now the rules that
make it so they can't do that to the
kids anymore
the stuff they used to make us do and
then we got in the stadium
and i was like i haven't been there
since i last played a football game with
nebraska and we lost my senior year i
haven't been back to the stadium so we
sit down and you didn't notice you were
behind me like i was sitting here so
they can't see i have my shades on
and i'm sitting there and then uh
i think see you scored a touchdown or
something everyone stand goes wild i'm
looking at the stands and some just
triggered something and god damn i
started crying i bet i started crying
because
well i was looking at the stadium which
was filled with students and staff stuff
like that but the one of the fondest
memories i have
is during that winter conditioning that
winner can dish so you can have 100 guys
on a team like 102.
but during spring and winter they bring
on more guys to try and fill the gaps
you know see if there's competition so
there's about 140 so they have to weed
out 140 guys that winter conditioning is
to weed out those guys to break them
mentally
so
i remember this uh star football player
bobby purify he did something he had a
girl in his room when he wasn't supposed
to on the road or he did something
nothing crazy we did something so we had
done with those sprints where i was
throwing up and gary barnett goes
running back so i was a h-back fullback
the only white guy he was running back
see me in the weight room after this and
you know it's troubling we're all i tell
my god we're trying to figure out and he
goes go put on your uh winter gear and i
look outside and it's it's boulder so
it's dumping snow like a foot of snow
the stadium's covering snow it's all
white
and he goes uh we go in the weird room
and he explained what bobby did i can't
remember it was
and he goes we're a team so when one guy
does something you all pay for it and
you're gonna learn today and he goes i
want everybody grab a 45 pound plate and
we're all oh my god 45 pounds [ __ ]
heavy so we're like okay and he goes you
see those bleachers out there and he
goes you guys are gonna run with the
plate over your head if any of you drop
that place you're off the team now now
you gotta remember there was only about
seven or eight of us it's almost life
and death because you're whole you want
it so bad then like yeah you're wrapped
up yeah my like if i would have got
kicked off the team like i have nothing
well i couldn't just be a student it
could have also [ __ ] up your whole
life people don't realize that when
somebody says i needed that you need it
so badly and you want it so badly that
where would you go from there your whole
everything has come up to this point
that's your identity yeah so i remember
um us running
in the snow everyone's slipping and not
a single person dropped that 45 pound
plate going and he put coaches at every
jesus everything he could watch us do it
and then i just started crying dude i
started getting a t like not like
no just like
not like tim kennedy crying
but just like a tear came out my dad
sees it
my dad goes i think he knew but he was
also
like trying to he was like yeah it's hot
out here sweating huh i'm like yeah
that's sweating
you know dude i mean the one thing i'll
say to anybody who's young is listening
is that
when you do go through those things
which is really what we what you're
really talking about in my opinion as i
think about these things because people
like to talk about discipline and grind
what was driving you was
a true love of something and and and
also you wanted something so [ __ ]
badly and i don't think anybody can
understand what it's like to want
something so bad that that's
my whole life has only been driven by
the fact that i want things so badly
i've wanted to be i wanted to be an
actor so badly i failed in a lot of ways
i also succeeded but yeah i don't think
people realize how badly um i still want
things and and how badly yeah and how so
many things get taken away yeah for a
thousand reasons how you just missed you
and i always talked about just missing
yeah and how we just keep kicking the
sand back down the road it's the only
thing i know how to do no matter what
you do to me and i'm not it's not about
being tough it's not it's not it's just
i've always been a kid and i know you
too that that when you and it's
important to isolate what you really
want yeah also really hard to go for it
it's really [ __ ] scary and and and i
think that's
kind of the lesson is is
and if you can't cry over that man oh
yeah
you know um the only thing i can relate
to on that the only thing i can relate
to physically on that you bring up high
school wrestlemania
no i know but but dan so but this is
what's interesting about it they said to
us when we started in iowa they go a
third of you will drop out yeah which
which happened and then they ended up
they closed the camp down the next year
because it was because you couldn't get
away with it anymore people were suing
because it was just too much you know
for free well that's right when i saw
matt mcchesney and lawrence vickers was
there i've talked to you about
lawrenceville she's just the most
inspirational guy ever and i said do
they still do like dirty done stuff like
no that's what i mean and i was like
that's right
that was my critique to the c team i'm
like they're not tough to like we might
not be able to beat alabama or george or
whatever but man whoever it was miami we
played [ __ ] you know texas a m texas
sc whoever it was dude we we you knew
you played us because we [ __ ] stuck
it to you
you know what happened to me though in
the difference between you and me like
after that i did that that [ __ ]
wrestling camp
i remember i i remember i went if this
is what d1 wrestling is i don't want it
i i don't want to do this i i don't want
to wake up at 5 30 in the morning and
sprint for an hour i i was sore i was
limping the whole time
like for me sometimes you just you
stopped doing it after that i just
didn't like it but this is where i was
uh
and i had options it was wrestling you
know it's not like football but he want
to be a pro he wanted his life to be
there's there's a lot maybe if my life
was happening yeah but but i this was
done chin about them below the belt but
it's also like when those kids would
quit like
literally my body or heart would have
stopped working for me not to make the
team like that and there but there's 80
of us like that there's 80 of us like
that we were there for one goal and
those other guys that would quit that
would give us
motivation to keep going so when a guy
next to me like i can't find like oh
[ __ ] yes that's a great thing it's like
a victory for you yeah
i used to love it yeah
yeah i love that story yeah that was
cool
because i think yeah you need this kind
of stuff well if well
but that bait i don't want to kill you
off but that that base and like that
mental fortitude and like toughness
like yeah not like we were fortunate
where i think 13 of our senior class
went on to the nfl which is unheard of
unless you're at alabama yeah but
nobody's playing now everyone's retired
but i think from going through that like
every although the main guys like my
main core group everybody's successful
everybody's doing [ __ ] yeah they're just
monsters
there's just no quit it's not a surprise
it's really interesting man it's it's a
it's it's uh it's a gift when you when
you admit to yourself what you really
want like really hard but yeah how bad
do you [ __ ] want it well like joel
klatt was our quarterback and he was
like our captain he was older than us
but you know he is
the voice like there's uh
there's i don't know if joe buck does
him anymore but there's the guy went to
ohio state curb streak who's probably
the most famous there's curb streak but
after curb street gets joel clatt
he's the voice of college football he
does the ohio state games he does big
time ball games but
he's the guy on fox and he was like our
leader man i do i think when you go
through what you described
as long as you did it changes you
fundamentally you can never go back from
that
that that is the inherent value of that
it's hard to break a person like that i
i it's just like you're gonna throw your
curveballs and stuff but i think once
you power through that it's like was
that harder than training in the ufc and
fighting yeah that's different not even
just it's different it's different
it's different yeah you you'll see
what's tough but it i don't know it's
just different i always wondered why i
always did i will say i was wondering
why you weren't
as nervous as a lot of people going on
stage on stand-up people because that's
really scary you know yeah but but the
difference through so much
it might be that but also with stand-up
like
um in vegas this thursday friday but
with stand up
it's like
i can do the work and prepare for it and
take out the variables like yeah you
might get a crowd who's tired on
saturday night or loud
but for the most part like the fail you
you failing as a comic is due to you not
putting the work in right so i and
obviously you were like dude you know
it's gonna take a while before your
headline i'm like no i get that that
doesn't scare me
but
i know that you wanna talk about work
i'm not scared of work so if i can put
together an hour set
and you know figure this thing out like
and i can control the variable where in
the ufc dude i can't control the
variable it's i'm fighting [ __ ]
travis a killer dude and i might be
really good but i can't control i i
can't control anything he does yes on
stage i can you're like a lion tamer
dude that's true i can contin
i can control it yeah and also i'll take
it up to you and i'll take my elves at
the comedy store following you or joey
did stuff like that all right like i'm
figuring it out man yes but then enough
time goes by it's like right i'm a lion
tamer you don't think i've seen like now
i've been doing over six years you don't
think i've seen these type of lines
before you guys don't scare me i know
how this is gonna go i know exactly how
this is gonna go exactly yeah it's going
to go good
and then if the one line gets out of
control and wants to roast or something
you know i've been doing long enough now
where i can handle that or if the
crowd's really tired i think the other
thing that that you went through and you
always go through when you really try
for something that you want is the
devastation of getting it dude yeah not
being in the wrong
that in itself is its own battle like
what are you supposed to do you go and
play like you know
like so much of that [ __ ] man so much of
that [ __ ] is i guess
you know um
there's somebody i know is really
successful who said after all my [ __ ]
this year he said hey welcome to the
disaster club and he goes he's 75 and he
goes i know this is nuts but you will
look back on this if you navigate it
properly and be thankful i was like i
don't know about that yeah but you know
you certainly won't feel that way but at
least
at least no matter what you go through
but i think most people that went
through what you went through would
probably just be like all right i'm
going to close up shop
i can't that was never if we didn't even
we never even talked about it
you know that no we didn't talk about
that yeah you and i were like oh we'll
just power through it they're like no
you won't yeah so like what do you want
to do dude like i'm going to keep
grinding over here on the road you hold
the fort down let the storm blow over
and i'll come back on and then that was
the plan yeah and here we are that's it
you just got to keep moving forward
that's the that's the only thing you can
do i mean like my father said he said
just keep kicking the sandbag down the
road it's a good metaphor because that
sandbag doesn't move much but it's nice
but you make a movement keep kicking it
you get stronger getting better at
kicking hey man my friends at grubhub
love restaurants and they want the food
delivered exactly the way the restaurant
intended all right they want to make
sure that they're protecting the
restaurants man because they love
restaurants that's for sure they love to
serve restaurants and they want the food
to be great when it shows up to your
crib because maybe sometimes you can't
go to dinner sometimes you got kids like
your boy here and i can't escape for
dinner or i can't make dinner because i
get a two-year-old on my leg i get my
own a five-year-old my arms i can't make
dinner every night thank god for
companies like grubhub man and grubhub
works hard to serve restaurants so they
can work hard to serve you today's
grubhub they're doing a little something
special for panera get free delivery
perk on your first order from panera uh
15 or more order through the grubhub app
or online grubhub we serve restaurants
did you guys know
that more than half of americans are in
a high deductible health insurance plan
it's a nightmare man or they're on the
hook for thousands of dollars of
deductibles co-pays sky-high premiums
not anymore man for many people in the
u.s concerned about the cost of health
insurance there are just no good options
there's not it's like being stuck with
an outdated cable tv plan not knowing
about netflix yes step your game up
there's a better way to do it
introducing crowd health it isn't health
insurance it's a better way to pay
medical expenses all right crowd health
is a community of people who are tired
of paying for a broken system all right
a place where you can get simple
flexible and affordable way to pay for
your health care we all need it man
being the crowd health community can
save hundreds of dollars a month and put
thousands of dollars back in your pocket
it's simple use uh using their app find
nearly any doctor in the country rank
from one star to five probably pass the
one star docs talk about your health
let's look for at least three one
probably shouldn't go to them
either way all right you can scan bills
throw them away crowd health takes it
from there press the button to receive
virtual care anytime anywhere crowd
health is a
uh
crowd health is able to offer amazing
prices because of his community of
health conscious members
for a limited time the final kid
listeners and viewers get their first
month free and after you've been a
member crowd health will include a
fitness wearable that's 30 days try risk
free plus a fitness wearable just go to
crowdhealth.com fit and just go fighter
at sign up that's join crowdhealth.com
fit promo code fighter crown health is
not health insurance it's community
powered alternative terms conditions may
apply join crowdhealth.com fit promo
code fighter
how about chappelle saw the cheerleaders
at sc which are you know they're
well-known cheerleaders they're some of
the best and then see you good
cheerleading staff
he was all i'll i'll beat them right now
i look
do you think that you could oh 100 well
what's funny though remember
i'm a world champion cheerleader yeah oh
okay like it's it's just it's just a
difference but i feel like they weren't
doing the stuff you guys used to do
no
they weren't tossing anybody in the air
they weren't [ __ ] i mean they were
but just on a very basic level people
got people have gotten so [ __ ] up
doing that
it's just like
yeah i mean they're just doing what's
within their range because like the only
time we're limited like as cheerleaders
like when we do like when i went to
louisville we couldn't do a lot of stuff
on the basketball court but on the turf
and stuff we could do yeah whatever so
you should hurt your champion he's like
that [ __ ] weak
[ __ ] he's like you basically [ __ ] i
didn't say that my dad was like
he's like what is wrong with the front
of my eye he's fired up over these basic
cheerleaders
not up in here i've never even noticed
one girl was 18 years old you ain't [ __ ]
[ __ ] you ain't [ __ ]
i was like oh my god can't bring
chappelle to a football game
i was feeling my nostalgia too yeah
right i was out there i was like man
that ain't [ __ ] yeah that's what he's
doing i kept looking at kyle i was like
bro i got that
yeah it's good to have nostalgia man
this stuff is a weird feeling man yeah
it's its own beautiful feeling bro how
about i won't say his name how about
that dinner we went to with homeboy oh
man you you brian would have said
something he's not as nice he would have
said something
no
i don't know i don't know him really
yeah so yeah uh
well i can say his name so leister who
loves monster by the way he's the best
if you ever get a fight call that guy
but uh
leester who i talk to damn there every
week like we stay oh do you still every
week all the time all the time all the
[ __ ] time wow
but he goes i'm gonna never get i don't
get scheduled so he's like hey this guy
that i know is a big fan he wants to
take you to dinner and we're like okay
cool so it's klopp austin you know jay
chappelle and me and then lisa two of
his wrestling buddies one was like
all-american oklahoma state and the
other
i forget maybe oklahoma monsters
yeah he was two guys
all-american as a freshman first time
you've ever seen klopp
no second time but every time i see him
i'm like you ever seen the shirt off no
he
you know the incredibles you know that
tv show yeah the incredibles that
cartoon that's exactly what it is
oh it's huge oh no no dude no no
no six five
uh has the worst diet in the world
eats doughnuts
i'm talking about a six-pack i'm talking
about a six-pack uh the craziest
physicality there you go
that's what he looks like and he's he
just lifts some weights not a lot he
doesn't really lift anymore no look at
him he's on the beach like that
his legs and ass he's built like
superman let's zoom in on him for a
second
oh that's better yeah
that's him
eating hamburgers and [ __ ] nothing he's
like that right now he's
but look at his legs his legs and ass
are a whole different thing he's a beast
so he's so he's at the dinner austin's
at dinner jay
and uh i'm sitting in front of lisa
chappelle's right next to me and then
the wrestler's next to chappelle and the
other wrestlers over there and then
lisa's friend's over there
and he's ordering martinez he's loud
he's loud and he's wearing like you know
he's older guy but he's very very
wealthy very very wealthy so you know
he's an goes he's one in life
yeah and his mind yep big time and
whatever neighborhood he's in and so he
comes and he's sitting down he is uh uh
like a robert graham slash [ __ ]
um
it was like it was like a button-up
collared shirt yeah it was black with
skulls all over it and had the matching
skull hat i'm like well definitely don't
wear that but so he's light but he's
loud and he's ordering martinis i'm like
okay but he's getting louder because he
was ordering a lot of those martinis and
he's with a bunch of big strong guys
yeah he's safe so you got a big wall
this waitress is there you know waitress
and that one the nicest steakhouse
grayson something in uh denver great
steakhouse garden grace garden garden
grace great [ __ ] restaurant so the
waitress there you know it's a little
cocktail waitress you know sometimes
they have their titties up you know they
get so she has her tits up in a push-up
bra and big-sized tits
nice looking lady you know
it's a nice restaurant she's dressed
classy there's nothing it's not hooters
she's your waitress she's uh bringing
drinks
so he needs another drink
he goes
mill the restaurant stands up yells
muffin top
muffin top and i'm like this what does
he have tourette's hey dude dude are you
in the 50s dude
no in a time machine dude it was like
going to
dinner with clint eastwood in 1960 yeah
then he goes come here sister he was
coming sister or as a drink and he was
muffin top and i thought he saw there's
a heavier set waitress i thought muffin
top to me means i went spilling over the
juice correct but he was referencing her
basically yes he was so she so she she i
guess find it kind of cute like bringing
another drink she's walking away slaps
her ass no
and i that's assault i go what in the
[ __ ] yeah so i text least her because he
can hear me i go dude this guy's a
liability here's the problem is if he
can if he gets worse can he do this the
the news isn't going to be you got to go
oh leester bowling this random guy rich
with a terrible shirt on slap and girl's
asses it's going to be brendan schaub's
group of friends that's right i was like
this is a liability i can't be part of
it dude so the food comes you've never
seen a human being eat an eight ounce
filet faster in his life i lured two
bites
i got to get the [ __ ] out of here so i
lied make up a story that after it was
like three hours before the show i'm
like yeah they actually need me for a
sound test so mean chappelle and jeremy
get going
and so uh he's like wait wait wait wait
wait and he's like in this side
you know
comic you know this stuff because he's
drunk and he was hey man i want to be a
stand-up comic when i was younger i'm
like well he's like you give me hope he
goes you give me help and i go oh thank
you that i find that
all right vaguely insulting yeah yeah
all right yeah so then uh he goes yeah
mountain dew style well there's open
mics in denver man i can get you a list
whatever you want to do and he goes yeah
man and in my head i'm like oh he's
gonna be he's gonna be annoying during
the show because they're coming straight
after that so i i text chappelle david
right and uh klopp and jago this guy i'm
telling you this guy's going to be a
problem we got to keep our eye on him
and i text lisa i mean hey lisa i know
this guy you know i've seen this type of
personality before i promise you he's
gonna be loud at the show it's gonna be
an issue at least she goes no he's good
man boy i go i i'm telling you now dude
the guy who goes there's a host then
there's two features then me the guy who
goes on second his name is david lucas
and he's a professional roaster he's
gonna wait literally he doesn't he
competes in roast battles yeah he's a
professional he'll go on ig live and
just rose fans and like destroy and just
like
so whenever whatever city we're in we
owe during his that not miniature bells
during his set we hope somebody heckles
them we'll come out the green room
because he's made people cry yeah he
shut the show down he says he sets the
tone like no one else talks after he
destroys you want to keep talking i get
two more coming they can do the same
thing so they pipe down he lights people
up
so
show starts i see i know where they're
standing there's five empty chairs i'm
like man i wonder where that middle
david's set they're going to sit down
and here it is there's a
miscommunication i didn't know the
miscommunication i thought he was trying
to heckle david and i warned easter so
that guy goes sitting next to lisa and
lisa goes no dude you're fat ass go down
go scoot two over put uh whatever jerry
here he's skinnier
and he responds loud and goes i'm not a
fat ass well david's on stage and he
just hears fat ass and david is a big
boy boy so dave goes what the [ __ ] you
just called me and we're all still like
this
oh no
he was what the [ __ ] just called me and
he's like knobbed fat ass but he all he
hears his fat ass skinny he was i'm a
fat ass
dude
that's not what i was talking about yeah
he goes who the [ __ ] let you out of the
house dressed like that my man he and
because there's black skulls over it he
goes you look like the shower curtain
from beetlejuice he goes hey he goes i
bet if he goes he goes i bet if you say
uh beetlejuice three times a gay dude
jumps on your back
and then just kept it just like lighting
lighting the shirts on buttoning is a
american flagship is that american flag
shirt he goes i know sure as [ __ ] you
got a fake vaccination card up in this
[ __ ] and dude 10 minutes just
lighting this dude his face is just red
dead just red crushed i text lisa
because i didn't know his
miscommunication i would i'm telling you
dude if he talks during chappelle's set
i'm working they're gonna kick him out
security went to him and he was like oh
it's a miscommunication but i didn't
hear any of that so it takes lisa i'm
like i'm telling you dude if he keeps
talking they're gonna kick him the [ __ ]
out i didn't know it was a
miscommunication
this guy has my whole body tight like i
feel tight
but he got like the hell yeah
yeah but like he's just he's just one of
those wealthy dudes there's just like
you see it all the time i think you know
what i'm talking about i think you can
do like greenlee
but yeah in denver i was like whoa yeah
yeah i was like dude are you from the
1950s yeah a man
of a certain age who's made a lot of
money hasn't had anybody tell them to
shut up there's an idea yeah there's an
ego you know khabib was talking about uh
that with a certain fighter who's very
famous uh and uh we all know connor yeah
and he said the guy got so famous that
the problem is that sometimes i don't
know if that's the case with conor but
this was something he said that you
could apply to other things
he said you you get really famous and
people stop telling you the truth you
make a certain amount of money
you need people who keep you honest yeah
right he slapped a table say come here
sister no no it's like no just straight
up just muffins and then slapped her ass
when she when he stopped i was like i
need to go now yeah that's i was like i
can't be part of you you got to run away
yeah we got out real quick
damn we should probably go like
more mashed potatoes like nah man
yeah that's a problem the mashed
potatoes weren't good though what the
[ __ ] is
going on oh it was it was it was so
uncomfortable i do stuff like that one
time this girl starts i was in texas
girl starts talking to me she's giving
me the business i'm just standing there
in a bar after it's in dallas you know
that dueling pianos bar yeah a great
place hanging out there
it's rocking i got a beer i come off and
she comes up and she's just like you
were that you were madison improv like
uh the that when they exit there's a oh
you get next door dueling piano yep and
i'm just sitting there and i'm listening
to this girl tell me that i am
essentially that i walk on water and i'm
just like thank you very much it's great
it's so nice to hear
and
she's kind of like she's at one point
she brushes me with her hand she just
goes like this like you're so cute or
something like that
like that
was she attractive or no sure of course
you know i don't know probably half my
age who the [ __ ] knows anyway i'll stand
there and uh
guy comes up sturdy looking kid sturdy
kid comes right up clearly her boyfriend
takes her drink out of her hand
just takes her drink well i think it was
a
[ __ ] like like one of those fancy sex
on the beach it tastes like just cuz
could just just because spikes it spikes
it enough's enough
like that she just
like he just grabs it tosses you take a
hand or face i know the next thing he's
gonna do is turn to me or something's
gonna happen yeah
i disappeared the way i disappeared
like i'm gone
i got to go oh i
diarrhea my face got hot i was like
why would you slap a waitress you run
away run away run in the other it was
uncomfortable we're there maybe five
more minutes yeah it'd be it's almost
like a spree shooter the guy's shooting
bullets i'll see let's just run out the
room look get the [ __ ] out of here
there that's a really important lesson
in life to know when to run the [ __ ]
away yeah yeah who is it
the best guy on the planet sitting there
going i i use my feet if you [ __ ] with
me if you're you want to fight me you're
in my face i'm running away if you're
messing with this i'm running away you
call me a big [ __ ] i'm running away
because i run away i use my feet yes
best weapon in the world yeah the only
time that changes is when i get grabbed
chocolate said that hey guys
the only time all of that there's a
black belt now that all that the only
thing dean lister is the only time that
all changes
is if you grab me
who the [ __ ] grabbing yeah
who the [ __ ] gonna grab that guy
people who don't know that he's chuckled
but just look at the [ __ ] he still has
the military standard cut his [ __ ]
cauliflower i was with mark turner who's
uh who's damian maya's one of damien
myers number one student ain't nobody
trying to grab me no [ __ ] yeah dude
that guy kisses
the [ __ ] the american flag out of his
dick
could he be any thicker two four no
one's no one's gravity you tell me you
wouldn't vote for him for president i
mean why do we not have a badass like
that as a leader uh he probably doesn't
want to do it look at that picture to
the right top uh in a black t-shirt
that one yeah
apparently he has really not a lot of
sense of humor he's just that way
imagine if he was go down there go down
there and if you want to see what a
naked ape looks like go down right there
look at him right here
high level high low high level that's
jeff monson that's that's jeff monson mr
grappling don't ever confuse him with
jeff no i think no no no
and jeff
yeah where
no no no no that's dean lister on the
left there guys that's uh that's
struggling no that that's chocolate it's
oh that is holy [ __ ] they're the same
but dean they look a lot like they look
yeah
mister but jeff they're just so thick so
they could they were fighting for
freedom there so uh jeff munson is an
anarchist
yeah have you ever seen the picture of
him and an argument yes i have you
understood there's swat guys in front of
him and he has a shirt off on the back
says like anarchy it's the
big ass
right there yeah he come get you some
he's a mom his nickname was the snowman
we got a capitalism and there's a gun to
the head i wonder what his opinions are
going on right now
how does he not have a rant
you're um look at his head
your boy least is a brawler
lisa is a tough dude
now that is a very very tough dude yeah
that's a fought in different ufc oh he
funny he's also a high level wrestler
thank you [ __ ] i love the
grappler grappler yeah
no black belts of all black belts dude
his tweets about covet and vaccinations
have to be insane yeah well he's gosh i
just because he can crush you doesn't
mean he's
on pointness he's a smart guy yeah
yeah very smart dad very very i haven't
i haven't done it yeah very well read
he's about as rough looking as a man can
get he's about
he's about as scary as him being the way
that he's facing darry is fighting
[ __ ] emelienko now i'll tell you
right yeah i fought fedor not today
right now that guy raised the capital
you got problems
you got problems if he raised oh yeah
he's got an anarchy somebody right there
[ __ ] face twisted off that is insane
go up to
that that one where he's facing up
there's that anarchy
and it says no master on his [ __ ] uh
gosh
he's a badass dude imagine if jocko is
your dad there's not a lot of there's
not a lot of feminine energy with munson
look at the forearms
oh he's probably yeah he was an anaconda
dude he's probably a kid how long is he
fighting ufc a while but he's grappling
he's one of the greatest grapplers of
all time oh [ __ ] mma fighter granted
russian citizenship of course
he looks like he's a russian he looks as
gangster as it gets look at that [ __ ]
[ __ ] what a [ __ ] great tattoo
god damn
he's a he's a he's a communist
he has a what he has a powerpuff girl on
him oh yeah he's a communist i think is
he correct but he's not
healthcare records correct
he's a different kind of communist
though
like i can get behind his
solidarity
what's funny is that he's incredibly
individualistic and in a communist
society he wouldn't be allowed pretty
nice guy though
uh i've had very few interactions but
very nice yeah he's not
he's not like aggressive or he's very
very nice kind of just oh okay you do
not want to be on the wrong side of that
guy no i'm good yeah no no i'm fine
wow are you saying russia now i guess
i think he's thriving out there
that's right that's right he's so happy
he left america right now yeah with all
the vaccine mandates and [ __ ] all that
stuff
what is this what is this isn't much
what is that uh true
you'll do what mr putin said
you do yeah that's true
the state in russia you're not you know
it's not like you go to russia and
there's a lot more freedom let's be
honest
you know a thousand two and 16. you're
different if you're gay elected local
council in russia
small city outside moscow
he loves uh putin loves fighters he's
47.
so he's uh
much younger than i am i feel like we
look the same
scroll down chin what's this
2018
scroll down though but yeah that's what
he's doing it says no it keeps going
down i was invited by the united russia
party to run but i'm independent
unfortunately i learned there are no
communists in communist party in russia
i have big plans for work with children
preparing various projects including
projects focused on promoting healthy
lifestyles
everything i do and i'm not going to say
it because i love russia
wow
man damn
he's right there are no real communists
in the russian
communist party they they all are
wealthy oligarchs etcetera and gotham
he's like what the [ __ ]
i thought you'll find way fewer
communists in russia than you will in
the united states because well they
lived through communism yeah and they
know how to remember in communism if
everybody has to be equal you have to
have someone enforcing that equality
which would mean
sir i know you're good at making money
in business but you have too much money
and you have to be you have to be worth
the same as everyone else which means
we're going to have to now confiscate
your property and allocate it to other
people what always happens of course is
that people who are you know
uh good at getting power and good at
influence they get into those positions
and they keep you yeah they're all rich
and [ __ ] right let's take a little break
from the three of us yapping your ear
off cause man all of us trying to get in
shape a lot of y'all wait till january
1st you don't have to wait man a lot of
y'all waiting for your gym to finally
open up back to normal and i'm telling
you right now don't wait man cause you
can get a great workout right from your
home i do peloton out of my frickin
garage all right i do it out of my
garage and right now pelton's never been
cheaper man the original peloton bike
now cost 400 bucks less so now's the
perfect time
excuse me to start building the momentum
to reach your fitness goals don't wait
for january 1st holidays are coming up
there's no reason to get thick in the
holidays or if you do like to go ham on
the holidays no pun intended if you eat
ham on christmas or thanksgiving you can
have those ham mashed potatoes pecan pie
cherry pie
uh sweet potato pie whatever pies you
want but you're gonna burn it off with
pellet on it's great man i do a class
every single day damn there or i'm on a
regular bike but i'm hitting the trails
because i'm the president of the thick
boy bike club if you're on peloton my
username is thick boy prez thick with
three c's all right they have great
instructors robin's my favorite ollie
ally's also freaking great curated music
whatever you're looking for hip hop
freaking country we got it all man you
have 20 minute workouts 30 minutes
workouts 40 minute workouts they have
class for every single level whether
you're a beginner my uh preference is
the tablet intervals you can really get
a workout in about 20 minutes your heart
rate's through the roof experience
motivation like never before with pelton
bike now 400 bucks less go to
1pelton.com to learn more that's
o t o o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n
dot com
behind every fight is a world of data
stats details same goes for insurance
man but find the right policy online
means comparing insurance companies that
all look the same it's tough man it's
annoying takes time
that's where my friends at the zebra
come in with the zebra you can compare
car and home quotes from every major
insurance company in under five monitos
giving you all the facts you need to
make the right decision it's the fast
way to find the right coverage at the
right price and they will help you find
a provider you can trust in fact the
zebra saves people an average of 922
bucks a year on home and auto combined
in other words they focus on the details
so you don't have to insurance is a
beast man and that's why the zebra is
here to save time and money in minutes
compare quotes for free at the zebra.com
fighter that's at the zebra.com slash
fighter
that's always
mistress who he had a kid with and he's
been with her for like 40 bring her up
please oh they found out she's worth uh
some like 100 million bucks that's crazy
talk brendan come on
yeah there she is
he's the ultimate
yeah i i begrudgingly he's like a guy
i like like a progressive i don't know
if i want him as my president but yeah
like on the outside looking in she must
be a badass that would be she's 46. who
is that dude yeah he she's been his side
piece forever but it's like nobody talks
about it you can't talk about it out
there
where's she at hold up
he's a badass
he's a badass yeah they had a kiddo
they had a kid but it nope like it's
just not talked about out there you see
in the papers or nothing does he live
the greatest life of all time though and
i don't know or is it just tremendous
responsibility and always work yeah i
don't know it seems like a house to kill
journalists and [ __ ] you know what's
that used to kill journalists and [ __ ]
if you're at a bad review you know
there's a whole apparatus of security
apparatus that'll probably do that
before you even
even
submit it
i mean
that his wife gymnast and putin marriage
at home
and there's this that's his wife
look everybody gets something out of
something there i mean you know it is
whatever i say she's worth 100 mil now
that's new york post by the way i have
no clue yeah
i know i mean i don't know
we don't know i mean
apparently somebody looked into it he's
about a four million pound
monaco
yeah he's a very special guy
he's a guy who you know
clearly has stayed at the top
of the most cutthroat
system and group for a long time
uh i think he's been president for
has it been over 20 years 25 years i
mean how long did yeah well since boris
yeltsin yeah you don't really want to
run again you don't really want to run
against him
[Laughter]
people have tried but they're still in
jail sir or they're just wait what or
they're gone yeah you know yeah there it
is berth yeltsin 99 so it's this year
2018 1990. no longer in eight years
right now than here since 1999. since
1999 he's lifetime president so yeah
it's a long time bubba this guy came in
it's 21 22 years now what'd you say chin
this guy came in the middle dimitri he
was also the head of the kgb
they're friendly now the kgb yeah they
they
you know
explain that to me
that's the scene
of russia
but
they're they're not as
they're not they're not as friendly as
ours run by the civilian government yeah
it's not like uh hoover here they're a
military organization yeah they run a
tight ship trailing us committee for the
state security was the main security
agent for the soviet union yeah they're
the ones right
such as
yeah
yeah they're stalling they're
another tough bunch
intense there it is
wow he looks like a friendly fellow
smart guy
black belt in judo
kgb spy school
hone their deadly skills during the war
jesus christ did you do any [ __ ]
no leg locks or all that uh no
just two leg locks but [ __ ] it's is it
not as
like judo and [ __ ] it's very like those
real real high level guys like obviously
fedor could use it in some instance but
in general he really wasn't using it his
arm bar was good because [ __ ] but like
i went against uh ishii who is a olympic
gold medalist for japan and judo and
judo
and he was heavyweight heavyweight how
did he flop
good he could because it's pretty easy
to negate their stuff because uh they
need under hooks they have to
they they try and get you off balance so
if you just
if you can neutralize their hips he
can't do too much it doesn't really
translate he just keeps his hips at a
distance yeah it doesn't think he has he
doesn't he's a great guy yeah i bet he's
such a good guy yeah he's my main
training partner the size of that
[ __ ] i know his head is a big
boy how much is he the nicest guy 240
but he's short he's like 5 10.
and and
this is not in any way
that's
what from eating a lot of protein
he had a clean diet i don't know he's
only just a big boy he's an olympian
he's he's thick the nicest [ __ ] guy
yeah barely spoke english had a white
girlfriend with redhead from newport
very true
very i mean how do you guys even
know you don't know his personality
[ __ ]
you saw that gold medal and jumped on
his dick you have no idea why was he
trying to have no idea what he believes
why was he training with what do you
mean in other words was he getting into
mma or was he just dude
ishii yeah mma dude okay did a long
career he fought fedor he fought so he
knew he knows he knew [ __ ] that he
thought
rampage [ __ ] look at that you fought
crow cop yeah dude
he's only five ten
and you uh you're about five ten and you
[ __ ] uh he was used to be main train
partners with the crow cop
god damn
he probably had 40 fights look up his
record chin strong fella super strong
yeah and he he would need a ghee to
throw you a lot of times right yeah judo
definitely needs a key yeah so he had 20
he had 36 fights
yes
he's still doing it man
jesus christ
but go down chin so he fought in uh
rising jesus christ he fought heath
haring beat him
uh lost the mo law
decision lost to quinn rampage split
decision
by the way the biggest legs that i've
ever seen a person uh is heath herring
no no you you saw uh
uh homeboy uh barkley for the giants
remember him that's the biggest like
you've ever seen sequoia second one the
biggest legs i've ever seen in my entire
cube well i said to you i go look at
that guys i don't know how you get
streaming and you were like you were
like oh you don't know what that is
saquon barkley now he's in born group c
on southwest so that bummed me out but
whatever yeah
yeah saquon's got some
there's some trunks on him any shorter
oh yes legs and he has some uh he's not
like real tall so it's even more like
it's like a horse's legs dude look at
him cur current play yeah super stead he
tore his acl last year and he's like
slowly working he had a good kick
yesterday but yeah go back you don't see
running backs that's just him he's
calves
he might be half samoan no he's not no
he's not look at those
black uh black black
i ain't got that
there look at look at that
those are just real legs that's a
[ __ ] gatorade commercial something
handsome kid by the way no that's a
dunkin donut super stud at penn state
too yeah
that's uh yeah look at this look at that
keeping girls look at that
i don't know how he has jeans i don't
know how he fits in the [ __ ] jeans
that's a sturdy fellow man
just run do you watch the games [ __ ]
uh i was flying but i saw brady uh do
his thing against unbelievable patriots
matt you always put up a hell of a play
a hell of a game against 19 straight
completions he showed up man i know it
was as far as the rookies he's
definitely the best that must have been
a mind [ __ ] to him though honestly to
play against tom brady against his
former team like that was tom brady's
team and he still played
very well against him he held his own
dallas out of all the rookies at all the
rookies back you know to be fair he's
probably the best yeah i agree well it's
it's it's not like lawrence isn't great
uh homeboy feels for chicago's not great
great brady might win another super bowl
oh yeah temp is [ __ ] good they're
loaded too it's unbelievable yeah i
thought they were gonna antonio brown
wrong house yeah worry about arizona
though
i don't know they're funny
yeah your cardinals are good well they
beat tyler murray yeah they they won
thirty seven against the rams these
football how bored are you to watch
football well
no because i i got back into it with the
hard knocks that that that [ __ ] oh
that's what i'm looking forward to of
course i'm i'm rooting for dallas now
i'm a huge dallas fan now there you go
on the team i want that i want [ __ ]
dak prescott after that injury i want to
i mean he's killing him and he signed
the biggest like deal he's [ __ ]
killing it and jerry jones deserves it
he's about to die
deserves it
you ever see what's crazy about him so
they have that new stadium so fight and
jerry grew up dirt poor and they showed
a picture of his childhood home is this
one bedroom home it's like a mile from
sophie grew up in l.a and then when he
was like a teenager they moved to
arkansas that's why he always drafts
arkansas players
he's self-made billionaire dude
yeah you said oh yeah you said they
practiced that jerry jones
dude man i love him i i just he's a
colorful guy no not that one
he's so involved with the cowboys he
loves his team uh type in l.a home or
whatever yeah that's just childhood
cowboys i can't remember anything i mean
i wasn't here
andrew was there as long as i've been
alive he has been
yeah
that's his home in little rock type in
uh la home childhood home
it was all over the newspapers out here
god damn look at this new house holy
[ __ ]
i drove by it
i don't see it
weird on the arctic area right here
uh what area is his house in uh dallas
oh well uh one of my friends was showing
me hmm
amazing yeah interesting
dude there was something i wanted to ask
her about brad inches did you see
weight inches
he texted me he said what are you doing
i said just got out of the shower he
goes let me see and i was like what did
he go oh [ __ ] autocorrect
because we're going to do something ours
come back from preschool what are you
doing dude he's jumping the shot but let
me see
lazy let me see let me see but oh [ __ ] i
don't crack just plain what are you
wearing just go bro
this guy needs to stop watching these
murder shows because you're alertness
for stuff come on guard all the time on
guard all the time so i was outside i
tried i was trying this denver condo at
the condo
and uh i moved the i was i don't think
he knew i was outside because i had no
idea he was playing angry birds on on
angry birds and play music yeah i wind
down at night yeah but he i thought he
was in his room because we should go our
set of rooms and doors [ __ ] so i'm on
the couch playing and i hear somebody on
the patio and i'm like well chappelle's
in this [ __ ] room right here like
i was moving a chair it was a heavy ass
like metal somewhere you're trying to
fight you're ready and then he's like
locking the door
and he's like going crazy and i go what
the hell's going i'm trying to
to see him run with this phone with that
music you were playing
he ran straight to my room and i'm like
i'm like yo you locked me out like i'm
like trying to like get a hold of him
but he was just like
he was alert that's my undies okay you
know he was on his own
apple pop his somebody comes in with
guns [ __ ] that
i uh hey two words
squid game
i can't it's too stressful it's not i've
decided i decided too stressful i've
decided that you'll uh
you'll you will watch it you'll probably
say i might say best tv show i've ever
seen in some ways just because of the
the
psychology the beauty of it it's so
interesting you like it beyond the
premise it's not it's not it's not that
north are there gonna be a second season
and i have a theory on it too it's also
a it's also an argument against
communism it's also an argument against
total equality but there's a message
it's stressful they're like competing
games and they die it's not it's not
stressful but it is suspenseful yeah i
wouldn't say it would stress you out
that's a great way it's better that in
my opinion i think it's better than game
of thrones [ __ ] you i agree [ __ ] me
too
yeah i think it's so young that the
korean version of it turns you off but
if you watch the american dub it's
perfect like no stevie
watch it in no you have to dub it so you
hear their voices the action is amazing
yes how's steve you watch it with this
stevie hates things that are dubbed he
absolutely hates that your lips will not
sync up to the words but he'll watch it
and he binge watches it oh no i'd rather
have subtitles on which you should do
with the real [ __ ]
in general see the real voices but i
always jump on things late like when all
you guys were sucking it off
yeah i'll give you two months and two
months get back together and once i run
it out once i run out of the crown then
i get that i can't watch two shows at
the same time you're being you're being
defiant and i get that i understand i
was that way with game of thrones for
five years i know my favorite show yeah
i was going to say you're visiting
with yellowstone i got it late but then
i binge watch i'm like oh that was good
and i talked about in here people were
like dude that was for you and i get it
i get it but this is this is the i will
say this about this at 54 years old it's
the most unique tv show and the most
unique tv experience i've ever had in my
life and that girl is so [ __ ] good
don't tell me they're so good so [ __ ]
oh i took time their acting is so good i
took tiger scenes i met him too
yeah yeah i was playing and i i [ __ ]
up and told him i'd take him to venom to
see venom this weekend yeah as soon as i
was like dad are we going do you have
tickets like yep
so straight from the airplane got home
dropped my bags off went to venom too
you're with tiger what time you are
cause my son's obsessed with venom and
he's just talking about yesterday have
you seen it yeah do you go do it do you
like it it's hard for me to sit through
those terrible movies but yeah yeah did
not hear good things no
like well my i don't really give a [ __ ]
about reviews and ratings because
anybody that writes things online i have
nothing in common with yeah because i
would never do that yeah because i like
to have a thought of my own actually you
took a chance on it when we went to that
coffee shop yeah i know well that got me
but um
jesus christ she's in the movie what
movie is she's on that movie
she's not in the movie
who is that i don't know she was in the
movie it'd be way better if she was
anyway uh
the movie is very uh poorly written it
like rushes through things like you know
how the first one got hate but i love it
the first one's
so good but this one's like
i actually didn't watch any of the venom
movies stevie's very upset with me about
that because it takes place in the bay
area yeah san fran i don't know i just i
love tom hardy too but the second one is
just like he did it for kids yeah he did
for his kids they tried like and i love
uh woody harrelson too he's [ __ ]
brilliant yeah and he was good in it but
it was
do you think it was a story
it wasn't great and then they tried to
make him venom like funny and then he
goes to this he jumps out of uh spoiler
in three two one he jumps out of tom
hardy's body because him i'm already
gonna fight and then he gets in another
body he's like i'm free and get he goes
like this rave where's like bi and
pansexual and
trans and he's like you know i've been
quiet for too long yeah you're like what
is happening what is this with uh woody
harrelson he's had a hall of fame career
he's had a hall what do you mean what's
this he plays carnage wow he's he's the
red uh guy there's venom who's black and
he's the red guy look at him he and his
acting's getting it but just yeah yeah i
thought the first one was kind of rough
too though i liked the first one people
hate the first one i loved the first one
loved it
the thing is you know it's pg-13
probably shouldn't brought my
five-year-old but um
the previews in the beginning
it is hollywood just regurgitating [ __ ]
over it's all the sci-fi [ __ ] like come
on dude but then they did a [ __ ]
preview for the new halloween which is
scary as [ __ ] and i've never ever made
tiger clothes eyes but that one i was
like oh you can't you'll just keep you
up at night dude that's right so i
[ __ ] close his eyes
and then i was like hey talk why do you
like carnage why do you like venom and
he's like talking to you didn't see any
of it but that halloween it's like what
the [ __ ] would you believe curtis yeah
they will get oh dude that'll work
is jamie curtis in this one yep no [ __ ]
yep yep as an older woman she's fighting
hey i was obsessed with her intro this
might be interesting
look at her
hopefully that one goes uh that's what
she looks like now not a very flattering
picture of her but
oh that's probably just for the movie
she probably still that's how she's
probably still got it going on
from like back in like true lies from
her true lives
in the days she realizes that scene is
realized where she like plays
oh yep you want the best hits on the
planet are susan sarandon when she was
younger and easy
susan
oh my gosh
all my children oh yeah
she's a beast take a look
she's got a crazy body jamie curtis was
built like damn so was susan sarandon
though susan saren had the craziest best
hits of all time uh if you actually see
her in this movie what is it called sar
sarandon
she from all my children
um but what was a was the movie called
brian uh it was called you just just put
in topless and you know not to be a
creep but she was and so talented
like she'd stop your whole life
yeah she was yeah all right needs to
calm down but
okay
all right
there's love
give me that they're real now you
probably have an image in your head yeah
we brought it up you regret saying oh
there she is
dude she's begging i think she's more
beautiful as she ages yeah
she's such a baddie that that said
that's her head on other bodies there i
don't think so yeah
do you think that's photoshopped yeah
the one in the dress there's a movie
where she's in the window and she's just
you know
no we've seen her tits dude what's
suzanne summers looking like now
now yeah she's ann summers who's
talking about it you don't know suzanne
summers yeah you ever seen step by step
long time ago no dude that's the thing
yeah
kelly brinkley all right never mind
huh age
age guesses agent botox to fight you man
i forget y'all but she was a bad man i
was like
yeah all right
this is aggressive
the way you said jack off dang
no
yeah i mean well i remember a different
one
yeah we all remember it differently
because we live now in a time where you
where surgery technology diet
all that [ __ ] is i'll tell you
hey listen brendon yeah i'll tell you
who just doesn't ever miss there's not a
bad picture on the internet cindy
crawford
jesus christ i've seen her in person
she's astonishing yeah breathtaking i
saw her like four years ago in santa
monica like holy [ __ ] she's birthday
yeah that's why she and her daughter
she's the most famous
woman her daughter was on american
horror stories this past her daughter
was just like her too she when she was
younger she looked like she was from
another planet i mean you know she's got
a cuter doll
daughter is her spinning image yes
go to the top uh left one now her top
left
her husband is uh wow
yeah is her husband the the surfer uh no
that is laird hamilton i saw him at
irwin her husband is a guy who owns um
uh the world yes he owns uh uh what the
[ __ ] randy gerber her brothers
tequila company with george clooney
he owns a bunch of restaurants yeah
easter eggs damn they've been together
forever they've been together forever
yeah he owns lots of famous places she's
so [ __ ] pretty even as an older lady
mike gone yeah breathtaking all right
jim what do you got he's that tall
handsome son of a [ __ ]
before we get into that i did want to
ask a question b what i saw a tweet this
weekend i don't know if you have uh-oh
um
from joel klatt actually
someone uh tweeted to him saying like
what's the best story about you and
the story he told tweeted out made me
want to ask you what happened so
the story that he was talking about was
saying how you got into a skirmish
outside a local establishment one night
and that you kicked someone in the jaw
and that all you could think about was
how you got your
leg that high and i was just wondering
what happened now this is the tweet that
jolt sent it yeah
um
yeah he's talking about i think because
you know he's like the face of fox now
so he does q and a before the big games
i think some person was like who gives
your best friend and shop story
so clyde used to be a wild man and then
he played uh i think triple a or single
a baseball did that and then came back
to college so he was like 26 and we're
like 21 is weird
and then and then yeah and then he real
smart too he's basically having a coach
as a player was weird he like judges
free drinking [ __ ] but um
we got a party bus and went downtown so
it was klopp me joel klatt some other
guys
and uh we're out drinking you know i'm
21. i just turned 21.
and we were walking down near uh 16th
street mall we were walking on some bar
and i was drinking jameson
and uh we're all pretty tipsy and there
was a group of russians talking [ __ ] to
a group of armenians but we're in the
middle but we weren't paying attention
so i thought the russians were talking
to us talking [ __ ] to us it was like six
russians
but they weren't they were talking over
us to like we just had to be walking by
so i thought they were talking [ __ ] to
us
so and you're 21 at this 21.
and so uh a fight ensued with these
russians and cop and clotter like the
[ __ ] there's no fight what is he doing
and where is he fighting these guys and
i thought it was chaos there it is
let's hear a good brent shop story he
got a skirmish skirmish quote squirmish
outside of local steps and when i kicked
it doing the jaw i just remember
thinking how did bren get his legs so
high i had jeans on and boots on and
i didn't know you could kick back then
but he did take taekwondo
uh not really i mean
yeah you know not really my dad made us
but it's lame but uh so i thought all of
us were fighting i thought it was this
was the russians so i thought
everybody's fighting but they weren't
they were standing back on what are you
doing and i was so hammered i thought
everybody's fighting so these russians
came at me
and i you know i'm hitting these
russians and they're falling down and
then one just ran straight at me i
remember thinking what the [ __ ] is he
doing and remember at the time i was
like balls deep into pride fighting with
crow cop and fedor and before we left
that morning i watched uh fedor and
krokop fight and like the highlights of
fate were like knocking out all these
guys like vandelay with head cakes so
that must been in my like you know just
in my subconscious mind so when this
russian rap me i just in my [ __ ]
levi jeans and boots i head kicked this
russian knocked him out
and that's why and clobbered and then
cops like alright mary clapper clap grab
and goes run because the could hear the
cops because i [ __ ] these guys how
much did you weigh them you were huge
two four no 240. that's big
football i was small you all kind of was
small she's like 190 but in shape klopp
was the biggest 40s that's that's not an
average size first four football players
whatever you're 21. but then i remember
i remember the russian pulled out a
knife on clock and clap grabbed his hand
and crushed it like like i just remember
clap grabbing it like get out of the way
and then like this and then squeezing
this kid's hand so you know they were
they must have been they were older than
us i remember crop crushing his [ __ ]
hand to let the knife go and clap
grabbed the knife and just chucked it
jesus christ i remember they're like you
better run i was like why we're all in
fights like just you are you idiot like
what
and clap
i bet clap cause that he has a picture
the next morning i stayed crap we
crashed at this [ __ ] a hotel but i
was getting back i had an impala back
then old school impala and he has a
picture of me when we got dropped off
from party bus in uh boulder because i
kicked that guy ripped my jeans because
i kicked so high i ripped my jeans but i
knocked them out and here's a picture of
me like just my hair i have long curly
hair i just like pure death getting into
my car i was like wait wait that's the
picture
i got to see that picture that's what
clatt's talking about there all right
all righty it's a great shirt jen i've
seen that a hot second very first one
big number maybe we'll bring those back
in january maybe wink maybe
um
wait i don't think any loaded cats stuff
yet hold up is the internet still being
dicey well
facebook whatsapp um instagram instagram
they're all down
this is like the longest it's been down
too i don't know how owned by the same
company
yeah it's kind of a nice reprieve
good
oh real quick while we're on that
subject real quick this is what edward
snowden
tweeted about
so facebook whatsapp and instagram are
all going down at the same time sure
seems like an easily understandable and
publicly popular example of why breaking
up a certain monopoly into at least
three pieces might not be a bad idea i
think so somebody should tell elizabeth
warren i think there is a
when you guys freaking out
i live in l.a we've been getting emails
about it so newsome saying kindergarten
through 12th graders mandated uh vaccine
mandate here's the thing about that it's
gonna be a bit of a hurdle to go over
because a
they're not gonna do any of it until the
fda approves it and they have to do more
research on so it's gonna be a hot
second before they do that oh they're
not just going hot
hot hot second and then what else is
complicated is
if you're a teacher you can decide not
to get vaccine and there's no issue but
if you're student union yeah but if
there's a student let's say you have
some issue there's no exceptions yeah
what a surprise the teachers union is
incredibly powerful now where is that
one of the people's one of the groups
that got him elected yeah so politicians
they're visual news
gavin newsom is such a politician in so
many ways such a piece of [ __ ] such a
such a [ __ ] politician
alrighty so the first one
yeah but don't freak out this does a lot
of loopholes that's jump the fda and all
that is so funny you guys trying to sell
a catalytic converter yeah so a man in
missouri posted a photo of a catalytic
converter that he was trying to sell on
facebook marketplace in the background
somebody noticed that there was meth and
a syringe and so this person who noticed
it uh called the police let them know
hey there's a facebook post of this guy
trying to sell this thing and there's
meth in the background so police
officers got a search warrant showed up
to his house and by surprise he's like
what are you guys doing here why is
there a search warrant they told them
about the photo and they found
some of the meth still left over as well
as a illegally owned gun nice gun
that dude
yeah he snitched on himself
i mean yeah he kind of he kind of did it
to himself yeah
initially yeah
somehow that's a lot of meth yeah i
think it was now or never i mean it's
like it's gonna happen sooner or later
well also meth is gonna put you in your
own jail so i mean god's message jesus
christ yeah you're selling capital out
murders which is probably stolen the
first place that's what people do
this guy's an idiot
yeah other things
talk about that's a bent spoon with a
syringe
[Applause]
is
yeah yeah
like okay that's what i was looking for
my catalytic converter is out how would
you even know
yeah
all right
all righty um just checking out the
price oh i'm just curious how much it
was
maybe
it can't be mine take a rough guess
so there was a customer walking around a
toyota dealership looking for a car when
they noticed that there was a woman in
the back of a jeep doing something and
she was naked upon like walking closer
to the jeep they noticed that she was
masturbating so this customer goes and
tells someone who works at the
dealership like hey this is going on
and the dealership gave her a few
minutes to get out of the car get
dressed and leave the premises when they
finally get the car back the radio is
busted there's a terrible smell and
there's a period stain on the scene
where she was sitting police officers
later found her walking down the street
away from the dealership and she was
arrested she's not in her right yeah no
there's no way she's not in her right
mind she's just you know that's somebody
who's not well and that's a bummer so
she she damaged cars and tearing killing
a broke so she broke the radio that's
the biggest thing
she's just not she's not all there man
no she's not right in the mind bomber
that's somebody who needs help
already
so i think the more we learn about um
mental illness like in 30 years we're
going to be like look at how we treated
those people oh look at how we thought
they had control over themselves
that's what's gonna happen i think
yeah a turkish man went out drinking
with a bunch of his buddies one night
and he was just that friend who wandered
off and disappeared without telling
anyone his friends realized that they
didn't hear back from him for hours and
they got so worried that they formed a
search party they went and asked local
community members police officers to go
help and there was this huge search
party trying to find this man somehow he
heard about the search party didn't know
who they were looking for and decided
that he wanted to help so he's walking
around the woods trying to find someone
but i'm worried about him and after
several hours somebody started shouting
this man's name like hey come out we're
looking for you are you okay and he's
like why are you guys screaming my name
i'm right here we're trying to who are
we trying to find he realized he was the
man that he was looking for that's like
when i was we we lost the keys at the
beach i was i was so high and i'm we're
looking everywhere we're retracing you
know you're on the sand that's a
nightmare you're retracing every step
footsteps we're like what are we going
to do before uber this is all no taxis
this isn't we were in atlantic city in
jersey 45
1945 9 35
and i i sit down and patty jenkins
there's my friend i sit down in the curb
and i'm like [ __ ] you know and we've
been looking for two hours they're in
your hands she goes brian what's in your
hand
i was like oh man the keys
of the rental car yeah
yeah so fresh there you go
so eminem recently
uh created a new restaurant in detroit
where it's called mom spaghetti they
have four items on the menu spaghetti
spaghetti with meatballs spaghetti with
vegan meatballs and a spaghetti sandwich
yeti this piece sandwich looks
disgusting though do you want anything
you want to eat that sandwich uh
i tried that sound i've tried the
spaghetti that looks pretty [ __ ] nice
it looks almost like garlic bread yeah
yeah that looks that's what i'm saying
that would be good yeah i bet that's
pretty good yeah it's real good it's in
detroit spaghetti yeah it's called mom
spaghetti it's in
detroit and on opening day he actually
went and surprised a bunch of fans
myself
yeah
that's uh
a great song great lyrics i just
listened to those lyrics how many more
we got should i get a piece so bad uh
just a few more you want to take a break
yeah it'd be great all right
let's call it it is amazing that you can
pee without using your [ __ ] hands oh
yeah i'd be [ __ ] it's athletic
water's cold all over the [ __ ] place
water's cold tell you that much you
little pistol you little [ __ ] pistol
bang bang bang
let's go he's a [ __ ] pistol pistol
there's a little pistol he made a little
funny joke and i was like you're a
pistol bing bing bing
maybe
that's the noise of a pistol yeah oh
yeah and now i was down there these
couch down there and they were like ding
nah my guns were going
kevin hart has that one yeah
pew pew pew pew pew pew
don't talk about giving heart
[Laughter]
some girls like guys make the best
noises with their mouths i'm like i
don't know what that's how we talk you
make the funniest noise
that's what she said
so you make the coolest noises
it's like i wish i could make noises
about how do you do a gun that was like
are you hanging out with an 18 year old
a long time ago
i thought this is recent well you're
pretty good at it
your whistle
hey
like
dude
you're trying to do it you got chin
uh this is a little bit old but i really
bring this up for a reason so this is
like last week lebron james confirmed
that he took the coveted vaccine they
then they say it's not my responsibility
to get people to get vaccinated yeah he
said that she's just doing it for
himself right and his family whatever
but he was also very outspoken against
it before yeah and then scientists so
and then i read
and this the nba actually announced like
days later it was to withhold pay of
unvaccinated players who missed games
because kyrie irving who's a superstar
and there's another guy on a team where
he's the only one not vaccinated
which is weird because is he really a
threat if i know if he's the only one
and everybody else is
i don't know what they're gonna do it's
gonna be a dicey man because you know
and historically in the african-american
community they've always been skeptical
of vaccinations rightfully so
so it's like you know the nba and you
look at people that aren't vaccinated
you look at the demographic and the
ethnicity a lot of it's
african-americans so
i mean you're not going to allow these
guys to play but in certain cities
they're gonna have to be so
for instance kyrie irving comes to
denver who's super strict or come to
maybe staples center i think we're gonna
be strict here he just doesn't play so i
think he's not gonna be paid for the
games
also if you're a teddy roofing do not
have the access to fake this [ __ ] dude
can i have an agent to help you out
now what are you doing dude you have all
the money in the world
you can't pay some doctor a hundred
grand to give you a fake vax card i
don't know how much it is
yeah he does
and then just don't say you got it you
don't have to announce the world you got
vaccinated or do
um well there's that 90 of leaks fully
vaccinated says
90
yep
um so they're really going hard on that
10 percent how do you guys feel about
the
halftime show performers doctor eminem
snoop and i thank mary j blige
and kendrick lamar how are you going to
out dude that's pretty cool
that sounds like a throwback to when we
used to keep it real back in the day oh
tell them brian
i like that
kept it real back then snoop doggy doggy
snoop dogg has kept it he's been
relevant for 90 years yeah we were
talking about the other day how he does
it yeah he just stays real i love him to
death he's amazing that'd be good
there's one person
yeah he doesn't say no yeah he's like
samuel jackson you know you didn't say
no to anything yeah who uh are you
talking about snoop dogg yeah yeah it's
a smart way to go about it he does
corona
when you point out
i was like this we're at the spike
awards and i go guys little and he goes
that's the that's the most popular
rapper in the world this is when like
you jumped yeah yeah yeah on the scene i
was like you know who that is
he's like he's tiny he is a little guy
kendrick lamar dude he's that little guy
you're at the the guy's choice awards
yeah cause i was like that will never
come back no
men's only awards
[Laughter]
in what world
should be i didn't even know that was on
facebook
yeah they're never going to do it though
run by a woman
oh the men's choice awards for spike the
head of the network where's the woman
oh this one that's scary
i knew her she's great
hey girl uh
i'm sure if you just scroll down to be
top one
well this was facebook's mastercard
reportedly deleted which means facebook
and instagram will be gone forever oh
wait a minute
that's kind of interesting
so someone deleted the large section of
the routing that doesn't mean facebook
is just down from the looks of it means
facebook is gone
in which facebook
has twitter
instagram instagram instagram i don't
know if they own twitter oh okay uh yeah
they own twitter really pretty sure
somebody [ __ ] hacked into facebook
yeah
employees can't enter buildings no
because you know you twitter's still up
yeah twitter's fine oh something they
don't it's whatsapp facebook instagram
which are all the same but check this
out
the employees can't even enter the
building because their access badges
aren't working
this is very interesting is this more
than a dns error someone literally took
them offline facebook is literally gone
holy [ __ ] wow facebook.com is for sale
what the hell yeah these hackers are
bees
damn this lady says the version of
facebook that exists today is tearing
our societies apart and causing ethnic
violence around the world in myanmar
they they had that
i wouldn't give a [ __ ] if facebook goes
away
it's great i don't know anyone that's
still on it i appreciate it's definitely
an older demo yeah but facebook but
facebook has more users than any other
platform you know that really yeah
can you go back go down down i got rid
of facebook that guy's face is really
troubling
oh you don't want to watch this jen it's
give me it's a he's like
there's a big storm and school's been
canceled yeah
you know what i mean yeah like we're all
like
i don't have to worry about instagram
you don't have to worry about it yeah
let's go chill
i wish i never saw all the people who
have sponsorships on instagram it's gone
like if it's gone then like it's done
yeah yeah yeah
cat
yeah i'm gonna have to get a real job
yeah [ __ ] okay wait what about tick oh
tick tock's his own thing right tick
tock is its own thing yeah it's not real
13 year olds would be pissed if tick
tock went down i'm enjoying this
throwing their phones and yeah yeah
honey nice
i mean we i mean instagram instagram you
kind of need though right yeah it's
going to be kind of tough
all your all your dates and stuff like
that wow
it's good to promote it yeah twitter you
still have but instagram is probably but
i'm sure you can figure it out yeah
something will take its place right
quick yeah
yeah people always figure it out right
quick but all those years of all your
pictures all that but who goes through
old [ __ ]
i mean does it really matter if they
delete it i don't care i don't care
check this out holy
apparently it's a giant gator eating a
six foot gator holy [ __ ]
that gator is huge [ __ ] what a moment
how did you not record it attack i know
dude that's a six foot gator oh my god
he's swallowing the little yeah that's
that's the size that's a human being
my parents backyard
no country living size of that thing
apparently the gator that got eaten what
ate another gatorade
no yeah oh it's like a turducken type of
thing
that is amazing that that's a dinosaur i
could watch these kind of videos all day
oh yeah that's a [ __ ] dinosaur and
that'll eat you yeah uh-huh that'll eat
you if you fall in that gator that big
that's in your backyard why does he have
nuts hanging out the side of his neck
he's big leather nuts yeah those are his
[ __ ] gels i guess i mean he's just a
giant head he is [ __ ] enormous
i bet that other algae is like what the
[ __ ] dude
same same bud same same
i'm on your team yeah but i'm starving
you're really small
six feet that's pretty big that's insane
six foot size human being
um i don't know if you guys care about
this but this is kind of cool to me hey
what's in your hands uh
a couple bought the home the original
home that they filmed it in uh-huh where
is
i think it was in burbank yeah something
like that i think um and they're making
a little museum that you can actually
tourism if you does it let's say what
city it's in i forgot what it was ursula
and terp museum
classic tampa
close
yeah i've never seen the movie oh you've
got to watch it it's great it's a good
movie the museum two one movie isn't so
interesting i mean it's a big movie but
is it that big of a movie where you just
buy a museum
what do you mean museum yeah there's die
hard fans like i'm a die-hard fan too oh
yeah i wonder how many there are they
only paid like 200 7 000 for the house
that's cool oh
and the the couple are actually look
really weird kind of goofy i think yeah
they probably wish they were [ __ ]
johnny characters
joey klopp dude how about that brian
laundry still on the loose
you think he's alive
i don't i do you do yeah because the
parents covered up all his tracks and he
left with cash and three
uh phones
and they think they saw him in canada
someone saw him in on the way from north
carolina too someone was saying that
they just
yeah but then also the
the d8 like the fbi are saying he's the
easiest guy to oh my god those are the
people
[Laughter]
that's a couple that guy looks like me
in 10 years
you've got a man that's going to meet me
in 10 years
it's been 10 years
i made this investment
adderall and whiskey and that's kyle on
the left
after taking here
um but that that uh laundry kid yeah i
think i think he's on the loose
but the the fbi were saying he has the
perfect
look to
go away we can't tell because he's just
a white male bald head so if he puts on
disguise it's kind of a regular looking
he's really regular looking so they said
he can just shave all the way down wear
a wig or do whatever so it's gonna be
really tough to catch him
if someone saw him or is this 99 sure
florida fugitive
this was in uh north carolina that's
right
a hiker on the trail told he was 99
percent sure that
you see his feet and they think he had
like a huge head start because his
family was like yeah he's in his room
didn't you hear that freaking dog the
bounty hunter actually covered most of
the the real good evidence like that the
he was visiting or his parents visited
him at a campsite twice or something
like that yeah something like did you
see i saw uh some tweet someone showed
me i think jason to me they said hey man
can we just say if dog the bounty hunter
catches this [ __ ] guy it's not that
dog
bounty hunters like some amazing like
detective we need to look into our
resources that we give to the fbi
i was going to say but he's also a
celebrity i'm sure way more people give
him information you know not thank you
i think everyone wants to find this guy
of course i think dog yeah i don't know
i think the dog saw it uh an opportunity
to make some money he everybody was
getting [ __ ] because he was knocking on
the parents door
and they're like get the [ __ ] out of
here dude
hmm but if he does catch him that's
gonna be
he's gonna fully redeem himself he's
still got that hair huh all the hair
ain't going away he is amazing oh
nothing so you know he's from aurora
colorado right from my hometown and then
he moved to hawaii for like a year and
started saying brah all the time
he started talking like a hawaiian and i
was because i didn't know he's from
aurora i was like i thought he was from
hawaii yeah why didn't you start using
the n-word
yeah oh yeah sir the answer is all his
life
i was like he got fired he lost his
entire head
he lost his entire job he's back with
this but
he's on he's on network tv but if he
does catch this kid and he gets on there
he like has them by the neck he's like i
just wanna apologize for frame the n
word this is how i'm to repay society
everyone be like okay
all right you got him
he looks ridiculous oh i think so oh
you've seen him in person no
on tv
around his uh you're [ __ ] right he
does dude
and his hair 70. that's me theo in 20
years oh
[ __ ]
it looks just like theo yeah yeah and
where's those weird like oakley
sunglasses that volleyball players only
that's an eagle feather by the way
that's that's that is dude he's probably
got he'll tell you he's got some native
american and yeah oh and there's of
course he does on the necklace and then
people are mad because his uh wife beth
with the biggest hits of all time
the biggest titties if you ever watch
that show they were so distracting she
would like run and hook guys down yeah
and then she passed away and then he
like married her friend like a week
later he said he would never marry
another woman again either and then he
married her
make sense grief will do that to you i
don't have any problem with that she's
dead what are you going to do
yeah yeah uh what is what did his so his
wife had i can't remember his wife i
think breast cancer she died
those tits were so big those had to have
something it was cancer i know it was
cancer i don't know i'm not sure if it
was breast cancer though you've never
seen her trying to hack down a [ __ ]
fugitive with them big tits it's insane
she had the [ __ ]
andrew dice
gloves on yeah wow
that's terrible terrible yeah
[Music]
beth chapman
that's a bummer
you want some more are you good i think
we're good all right cool
well guys come see me in uh
uh we're at my columbus ohio you know
where you're at saturday another show
that's right then we got uh october 14
15 16. i'm gonna be i'm going to my
goobies
let me know how it is i'll do it in a
timonium maryland magoobies
and then i'm in uh well i'm in
cincinnati liberty township uh october
22nd 23rd
going all to dover city tough tough
october but we're gonna have some fun
we're gonna have some fun
that's the mud run it's gonna be let's
go some fun and then i am that's cool
graphic
where is that oh that's san antonio uh i
am in las vegas this thursday friday
saturday las vegas wise guys first
headliner there uh brand new comedy club
right downtown las vegas for the locals
come on out wise guys las vegas this
thursday friday saturday that's october
7th through the 9th me and david lucas
will be there then october 15th that's
next week the 15th through the 17th
break california bray improv one of my
favorite spots chappelle's favorite spot
if you recall yeah and then november
11th through the 13th is one it's gonna
be a special night dudes i'll keep you
guys posted we'll get closer to that but
that's addison improv dallas texas
november 11th to the 13th chicago is
rescheduled because i have to be here
for a cal best fight campaign because
the giant ufc
so i'm not going to reach chicago but uh
this week vegas see you this thursday
friday saturday brea next week yes
and then october oh oh sorry this
weekend i'll be in tampa florida and
then uh october 28th through the 30th
i'll be in washington dc then i got some
one-nighters coming up november 17th in
tacoma washington and then november 18th
uh spokane all right kids that's it
vegas see you this week love you bye